all right let's go next to
Adrian from San Francisco where I just
returned from Adrian from San Francisco
welcome what's on your mind today
good morning David how are you I'm doing
well
David I wanted to ask you about uh Gavin
newsom's uh
proposal for a constitutional amendment
for gun control and I wanted to talk
specifically about the third point which
is he wanted to ban assault weapons okay
I was curious what your general
perception of a proposal like that would
be number one in terms of policy but two
just in terms of uh public sentiment uh
okay so the third let's see I'm looking
at the list here of uh so raise the
federal minimum age for firearms from 18
to 21.
mandate Universal background checks
Institute a reasonable waiting period
for all gun purchases and I think this
is the one you're talking about barring
civilian purchase of assault weapons
that serve no other purpose than to kill
as many people as possible in a short
amount of time you're talking about that
last one right
that's right thanks for the corrections
so listen he doesn't include that I can
see in this proposal the exact weapons
that would be part of that now this is
often a sticking point for the for the
right wing gun people they go you know
these Democrats want to ban assault
weapons they can't even Define it they
don't know what it is I can I can uh
modify a gun so that it technically is
legal but then I make it function in the
same way I think that sort of misses the
forest for the trees first the question
is can the government legally limit the
choices people have when it comes to
arms and I believe everyone says the
answer is yes when you go to shoulder
mounted RPGs nuclear weapons grenades
all these different things almost
everyone goes well no yeah okay so the
government can do some limits once
you've conceded that
then it's a matter of where you draw the
line and people can disagree about where
to draw the line but there's a lot of
places you could draw the line that
wouldn't violate the Second Amendment in
any way you then get to okay well is
this particular gun an assault weapon or
not that can be figured out and for me
it's not the main sticking point for me
the big picture is there are some
firearms that truly serve no purpose
other than to kill a ton of people as
possible in a short amount of time and
it's totally reasonable and logical to
decide as a society you can have a
second amendment you have the right to
own guns you can buy Guns Etc but not
any gun here are some guns we are going
to put on a list I think that that's
fine and you don't have to know every
gun that would be on the list for it to
be a valid position
yeah David I think that's fair I mean
total agreement that when Republicans
want to get finicky on the ontology of
what classifies as an assault weapon
yeah it's totally just to obfuscate
that's entirely their goal right but I
guess you know from my very peripheral
understanding like the vast majority of
mass shootings are caused by pistols or
handguns so things that we would not
typically nominate or denominate as
assault weapons or AR-15s or things like
that yep so I guess from a public policy
perspective it seems almost like and I
don't want to accuse Gavin of something
he's not doing but it seems a little bit
like a publicity stunt or giving into
sort of public fears and perceptions of
which types of guns are scary as opposed
to the type of guns which are actually
most commonly used here's my shot on
this Adrian and you're making a lot of
really good points I believe that when
we talk about gun violence in the United
States we have three problems we have uh
suicide we have have
um what we might call
it's so it's so tough because mass
shooting I believe is defined as three
people killed or injured so like if one
person is killed and two were injured
that's technically a mass shooting and
then you have like these sort of
nationally newsworthy mass shootings the
ones with eight victims 12 victims Etc
you are correct that statistically a
much larger share of even what we call
mass shootings are committed with
handguns and not the assault weapons but
from what I recall it's still around 20
or 25 percent of mass shootings where
there is an assault with what we might
call an assault weapon a semi-automatic
uh rifle assault weapon type type gun
involved we can fact check it okay but
let's put that aside for a second I
think there's a couple different things
going on number one no single provision
will solve the gun violence problem so
the waiting period might do more for the
handgun violence the limiting the
weapons that are available or requiring
a different type of background check or
whatever each of these is going to touch
to different degrees different types of
shootings and I still think we need to
take an all of the above approach you
can always say this one provision would
only deal with 12 percent of shootings
okay if you've got 10 or 12 Provisions
Each of which will deal with some
percentage of shootings you're still
making a lot of Headway but let me say
one other thing Adrian and then I'll get
your thoughts there is also a reality
that the environment in the United
States because of gun culture which
includes the school shootings the Mall
shootings the theater shootings all this
different stuff
uh contributes to a really disgusting
and negative environment and I would
argue that on that basis even if the
semi-automatic rifles are only 19 or 22
percent of the mass shootings they
generate such Terror that it is still
worth doing what we can to focus on them
while we also deal with the handguns and
the other stuff
David I certainly appreciate you you're
very utilitarian line of thinking I
think that's the most that's the day
Reger for Public Policy I guess one sort
of point I wonder is you know every time
there's a media
a hustle bustle about banning AR-15s or
assault weapons I I think a lot of
people go out and buy them and so do you
think that in doing some sort of
publicity stunt because let's be honest
there's no way something like this will
ever you know reach a constitutional
amendment yeah do you think sort of uh
this sort of publicity statement you
know actually encourages more people to
purchase these weapons yeah I think it
does but there's sort of a there's a
double-edged sword to that if there
aren't a lot of shootings then the gun
industry and the gun people go it's
thanks to all the people that bought
guns you should go out and buy guns and
if there are a lot of shootings then the
gun people go hey it's really dangerous
out there you should go and buy guns
either way there's a large contingent of
the gun people that are going to say
buying guns and more guns is the
solution so I don't know that we
necessarily want to guide ourselves by
that
yeah that's fair I can't I can't
disagree with that well thank you David
I really appreciate the conversation all
right Adrian from San Francisco with a
great series of questions let's take a
very quick break and then we'll come
right back and speak to more people if
you're waiting to talk to me don't go
anywhere because we'll be right back